the movie is just packed with so many
iconic sequences and lines of dialogue
but is there any one moment that you're
most proud of when you look back on it
that you wish people talked about even
more not necessarily I mean I think over
the years probably people have figured
this out but at first I think people
just thought that's what I was like and
I was a very serious actress that was a
that was a role I was playing I'm not at
all like the character my heart is in
the character of Cher but but I do think
that people have figured that out now I
really like there's one moment I really
like in the movie where I and I always
felt like I was channeling some old you
know 1930s or 1940s actress or something
and I had some people in mind that I
just felt like I'm connected right now
but it was and my mom too
but when I get out of the car before I
get robbed and with Jeremy Sisto and I
just did this like lush thing okay I
don't know what it was but I sort of
brushed it all off I just thought that
was really like where did that come from
but I remember thinking it when I was
doing it it just felt like something
like my mom like a Marilyn Monroe or
Lucille Ball II kind of feeling and I
liked it
[Music]
[Applause]